what i want to do in this video is think
about how we can find the sum of the
interior angles of any polygon so what
i'm talking about is we already know
what the sum of the interior angles are
for a triangle so this the measure of
this angle is x this one is y this one
is z we already know that x plus y
plus z is going to be equal to 180
degrees but can we generalize this what
happens if i have a four-sided polygon
so
right over here some type of a
quadrilateral four-sided polygon it
doesn't even have to be regular what are
the sums of in this case what are the
sums of this measure this measure this
measure and that measure and the way we
could tackle this is to divide it into
triangles so let's do that let's divide
it into we can draw divide it into two
triangles it's actually an interesting
question given how many sides you have
how many triangles can you divide it
into and that's actually the most
important question and the reason why
this is important is that we can then
say well let's say that this little
angle right over here is going to be
let's see is going to be e let's call
this angle over here f let's call this
angle over here g
let's call this angle over here h so we
know what we're trying to find is a plus
b plus c
plus d but we know that b is the same
thing as g plus h
b is the same thing as g plus h
g plus h and we know that d is the same
thing as e plus f
d is the same thing as e plus f and the
reason why this is interesting is we
then see that the sum of the of of the
angles in each of these triangles are
going to be equal to this sum over here
so we know that a plus e plus g is equal
to 180 by the same exact idea up here so
we know that a
plus g plus e
is equal to 180 degrees a plus a plus g
plus e
is equal to 180 degrees so you take
those out you're left with 180 and then
we also know we also know that f plus h
plus c is equal to 180 degrees f plus h
plus c f plus h plus c is equal to 180
degrees so it's equal to 180 plus 180
which is equal to 360 degrees so the sum
of all of these interior angles the
measure of all of these interior angles
was equal to the sum of all of the
angles of each of these triangles these
non-overlapping triangles that are
divided into so the real crux if i look
at an arbitrary polygon let's look at a
hexagon here and it won't even be a
regular hexagon
one two
three
four
five and six sides so this is a very
irregular hexagon
this is a very irregular hexagon but
once again we can do the same logic what
are the what is the sum of its interior
angles well let's divide this hexagon
into into triangles non-overlapping
triangles so this could be one of the
triangles that could be another of the
triangles that would be the other
triangle and then we have this fourth
triangle right over here so we have one
two three four triangles and then the
sum of the angles in each of those four
triangles is 180 degrees so the sum of
all of these angles
the sum of this angle that angle that
angle is going to be 180 then you have
this angle this angle that angle is
going to be 180 then you have that angle
that angle that angle is going to be 180
and then that angle that angle and that
angle is going to be 180 and i think
what you just saw me do is i'm
essentially having i'm going to have 4
times 180 degrees is the sum of all of
these green angles that i drew here but
the sum of those green angles is also
going to be the sum of the interior
angles of this hexagon
because the sum of these four is this
one right over here that one is that one
then that's those two are those is that
interior angle that interior angle is
the sum of those two angles that
interior angle is the sum of that those
two interior of those two angles so we
get four times 180 which is 640 degrees
so the general idea is you just want to
split your polygon into non-overlapping
triangles and however many
non-overlapping triangles you can split
it into you just multiply that times 180
degrees and that will be the sum of the
interior angles so the next question you
might say is well okay that's pretty
quick i can divide things into triangles
pretty fast but is there a general way
of thinking about how many triangles i
can divide something into we know that
one triangle can only be divided into
one triangle we know that a
quadrilateral can be divided into two
triangles we know that a hexagon can be
divided into four triangles as they're
general and you might already be sensing
a general pattern here is there if we
have an n-sided polygon how many
triangles can i divide that into so
let's think about that a little bit
and just for the sake of argument let's
just assume let's just assume that n has
more than four that n is greater than or
equal to four or actually greater than
4. so what happens is so let me draw it
like this so i'm going to draw my
arbitrary polygon like this so i'm going
to draw two of the sides right over here
and then i'm going to draw two of the
sides over here and then we don't know
what's going to happen here just yet so
there's all sorts of let's say assuming
that i covered this up with like black
construction paper there might be a ton
of sides right over here remember these
can be irregular it might look like that
in fact i can put an infinite number of
sides here depending on i can make it do
all sorts of i can make it do all sorts
of crazy things to put a bunch of sides
right over here and you can imagine it
creates a very irregular
very irregular polygon but let's just
worry about what we can see well these
four sides right over here
these four sides right over here i can
make two triangles out of them one like
that and then one like that so we know
regardless of however many sides this
has so if this has n sides
if we have n sides right over here we
can use four of the sides to come up
with two triangles
we can use four of the sides to come up
with two triangles so four
four used
for
two of our for two of our triangles and
then how many triangles can we make with
the remaining sides so let's just
imagine different things every so let's
just imagine
every every remaining side other than
these first four i can make another
triangle with so for example if this is
if this is so i have one two one two
three four more sides so this is a very
strangely shaped octagon but it is an
octagon a very irregular octagon and so
you could have that's one more triangle
using one more side then i have another
triangle using another side and then i
have another triangle using that side
and then i have another triangle using
this side each of the other sides other
than those first four can get can help
construct another triangle and so the
other way to think about it you could do
this try to do all sorts of crazy
numbers of sides here and you'll see
that once we use these first four sides
to create two triangles every other side
can we can use to create another
triangle so four used for two triangles
and then every other side
every
other
other side every other side becomes
can used can be used to create one more
one more triangle so if i have n sides
so if i have n sides how many triangles
how many triangles can i create so let's
say let's call this the number
number of triangles is equal to
well if i the first two sides i can make
or sorry the first four sides i can make
two triangles
so let's say i have at least four sides
so i'm going to have two triangles so
it's going to be equal to 2
is going to be equal to i'm going to get
two triangles out of those first four
sides and then however many and then
however many sides i have after those
fours after i've used these first four
sides each of them are going to get a
triangle
so i've already used i've already used
four sides i used four of the sides to
get two triangles right over here and so
that i'm left with n minus four sides
and each of those n minus four sides are
going to give me another are going to
give me another triangle right over here
so once again if this right over here
let me this is a let's see this is one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten this is a decagon i use four sides
for the first two triangles and then i
have one two three four five six more
sides that i haven't used and each of
those can form a triangle so this is 10
minus 4 10 minus 4 for this decagon
so the number of triangles if i have n
sides i can just simplify this is 2 plus
n minus 4. so this is going to be equal
to n minus two negative four plus two is
negative two so the number of triangles
is equal to n minus two
and we already know from earlier in this
video that the number of the sum of the
interior angles is the number of
triangles non-overlapping triangles you
can put in inside of that polygon times
180. so we could say the sum of the
interior angles
so sum
of interior angles
interior angles
are going to be equal to the number of
triangles we can create n minus 2
non-overlapping triangles that fully
cover our polygon n minus 2 times 180
degrees times the number of degrees the
sum of the degrees per per
per triangle and so we have a cool
little formula here and i always do
forget it and that's why i always
rederive it but just by counting the
triangles and then and then multiplying
by 180 but this is cool because if
someone said hey i have a 102 sided
figure which i you know i won't even
attempt to draw how many what is the sum
of the interior angles of that hundred
and two-sided figure well you would say
102 minus two is a hundred a hundred
times 180 is 180 with two zeros so the
sum of its angles would be 18 000
degrees for 102
102 sided polygon